[Music]
Matthew McConaughey and white Camilla
alphas open up about their organization
just keep living which aims to help
underprivileged school kids one of these
high schools of kids that are live in
poverty three two percent dropout rates
and we offer them a safe place to go
after school two times a week where they
set goals for exercise nutrition they
have to do community service they have
to give back to the own community et
spoke with the couple at an event for
the foundation with partner Samsung's
new frame TV the frame challenges the
traditional black box TV created in
collaboration with designer yves behar
the critically acclaimed winner of a CES
2017 best of innovation award television
combines design with technology and
transforms into a beautiful work of art
when no one is watching samsung's new
television also automatically adjusts
color and brightness so your art always
looks natural regardless of the lighting
or time of day the frame displays your
choice of hundreds of professionally
curated works of art from different
artists and genres an added bonus you
can shop the art store for additional
pieces or display your own personal
photographs et was with the vice
president of Samsung's home
entertainment Eddie combs where he
gushed over the 4k TV and partnering
with Matthews nonprofit just keep livin
like Matthews because it's so unique and
he's so unique and the product that
we're working with tonight to tell his
story the frame it's probably the most
unique television anyone has ever seen
so when you marry those two stories up
together we think it's like a one plus
one equals three moment so it's
something that's very different what is
so special about the frame TV
we often say it's the most beautiful TV
you've never seen because actually it's
not about the TV it's about transforming
your life it's about transforming the
room so by having permission to put a
product like a television and places
you've never had permission to do it
before so sometimes it's just a
beautiful piece of art you put a
beautiful mat on it and it just looks
like you know the
Casso and you learn but other times it's
football on Sunday or it's it's your
favorite movie and it's a 4k high-def
high-definition television that you're
just you can just fall in love with so
it can be whatever you want it to be
whenever you want it to be and I know
other product does that
[Music]
you